[MUSIC PLAYING]
ED BACHER: Good afternoon.
Thanks for coming,
and I'm just going
to give a very brief
introduction to this talk.
We want to welcome Jet Lowe, who
has been a photographer for--
he's retired now, but has been
a photographer for the Historic
American Building--
JET LOWE: Survey.
ED BACHER: --Survey and the
Historic American Engineering
Record for many years.
I discovered his
work browsing around
online at the Library of
Congress and spent lots of time
and started corresponding with
him a few years ago and said,
hey, if you're ever
out in California,
come on over to Google
and show us your stuff.
So without further ado, I
want to introduce Jet Lowe.
[APPLAUSE]
JET LOWE: Hello.
It's a great pleasure to be
here to give a talk to Google.
I feel in some ways that
the program I work for
is part of an antecedent
to the kind of things
that Google does in making
information about things
free to everyone, because the
program I worked for was called
the Historic
American Engineering
Record and our mandate was
to document the technology
of the built environment.
Historic technology,
as I like to say,
from wind mills to steel mills
to even the shuttle discoverer.
And this program has
all the documentation
that I did over a 35 year period
of time becomes public domain
and becomes a primary
resource for people
across the country researching
the American architecture
and engineering.
And that program originated
in the Library of Congress,
which was founded by Thomas
Jefferson in the interest
of making information as
accessible to the public
as much as possible.
So what I would like to
do is go back a little bit
and talk about my
background as a photographer
and even the origins
of photography itself,
because a lot of people think
of photography as started--
as a large format
five by seven--
five inches by seven
inch plate that I shot--
the information
that film can record
on a piece of film--
and they still
shoot film at the Historic
American Engineering Record.
If you record that
information at the--
if you scan it, you have
information that you can--
the optical resolution--
it creates around a
two-gigabyte file for one image.
So there's a lot of information
stored on a piece of film
and that's why we plan
on continuing using film
as our base of documentation
because it's a lot less
expensive to maintain than
if it were digital only
to begin with, with all the
redundancy that you need to--
as you all probably know--
to protect data.
So if you've got a film origin
and you scan that, then you
use the digital scan to
access the information,
you only need to go
to the film just maybe
a couple of times in a lifetime,
but the data on the film
can last 300 or 400 years
without any further ado.
I like to talk about the
origins of photography.
I mean, photography and
the optical ways of looking
at things goes back pretty much
to the Renaissance when ideas
of the classics-- the Greeks
about perspective and optics--
were being reawakened as that
information that were actually
saved by the Arabs and then it
was re-translated into Latin
in the 13th, 14th, 15th century.
And the artist scientists
became very interested
in single-point
perspective because it
was thought of as
almost a virtual reality
way, that if you could
make events look more
realistic to the way our
eyes perceive things,
then you could make a much
more convincing image.
What I'm showing here is
a very famous experiment
that's been described
as sort of the patron
saint of modern engineering, a
guy named Filippo Brunelleschi,
and it's a perspective
experiment.
But what makes optical
perspective in photography work
is that you're looking at
things through a single lens
and that puts everything
into perspective.
What he did is he did a very
realistic single point of view
painting on a mirrored surface,
which you can see here,
and then he would look at
it through this peephole
at the vanishing point
of the perspective
and then compare that
by dropping the mirror
and looking at the object
that he was trying to render.
So this is the
baptistry that he was
trying to depict in a
realistic form of perspective.
This is an image made by
a gentleman who studied
these experiments very closely.
And then this is where
the point of view
was made of the
baptistery in Florence.
And here's the significant
thing that he was trying to do--
if you can render images--
three-dimensional
images-- realistically
and proportionately on a
flat piece of surface--
on a two-dimensional surface--
you can make plans for
things in your mind's eye
that are much more efficient
and much more realistic.
You can work out your ideas.
So it was a form of thinking
that we worked on artistically
and scientifically
for 400 or 500 years,
and they're still
doing to this day
when we do laser scanning
and that kind of thing.
Basically, when
you're doing that,
you're pinpointing the
location of all these millions
of spots in a cloud when
you're scanning a building
or structure.
I managed to get over
to Florence, Italy.
I've been studying these
experiments and the history
of perspective, and
it interested me
quite a bit as it related to
photography because basically
viewing things
optically took place
several hundred years
before they figured out how
to actually fix these images.
And this is the baptistry
as seen about at midnight
in Florence in 2011.
It's so crowded there
in the springtime
that photographing
it in the daytime
is really actually
quite difficult.
Now if you turn around
from this point of view,
you'll see the facade of the
cathedral, the Santa Maria del
Fiore, and you can
see the enormous scale
of this structure.
And what Brunelleschi
was very famous for doing
is he built this enormous
dome without using
any internal scaffolding.
He used false work
around the edge
and used a very complex kind
of weave of bricks and stone
to hold this thing
together as it went up.
And here's another view.
You can see the-- just notice
the people on the bottom here
and it gives you a sense of
the size of this structure.
This is around 1450.
So it's one of the most
significant buildings in Europe
in a way in terms of structural
engineering and the machines
and devices that he invented
to get things up and hoist
the material up to the dome to
continue with the construction.
So basically what
I've been doing
as a documentary
photographer for these years
is, all of these
different structures
that I've photographed,
whether they're
in Europe or in
the United States,
I like to think of
them as kind of portals
into history or memory.
When you lose a structure,
when you scrape a building,
that kind of memory of that
structure is gone forever.
And here is a young man who
had the same notion as me.
He was kind of paying his
obeisance to the dome.
That's called the Giotto tower.
Giotto was an artist who
preceded Brunelleschi
by about 40 or 50 years
and in whose art you first
start seeing the beginnings
of a perspectival system
of rendering images.
Not long after-- about
100 years after this--
you start getting camera
obscuras, where artists start
using the projection
created by a lens
onto a surface to
create drawings.
And by the 16th
and 17th centuries,
you'll even notice
optical phenomenon
in paintings such as
like the art of Vermeer,
where they recorded these
optical phenomena that you
would not see with your
own eyes necessarily
but are created by a certain
slight area of the image
being out of focus.
So we have photography
for a number of centuries
before the chemists figure
out how to fix the image.
They notice that light
hitting silver halide
causes it to darken, but they
couldn't quite figure out
how to stop that action.
When they do that, that's
when you get the birth
of photography as we know it.
I want to make some mention
about how these perspectives
and how these optical devices
gets to be systematized
and then artists
start learning how
to make many other
kinds of projections.
And this is very soon after
the Brunelleschi experiments,
but you will see often that
this kind of system of thinking
is often used in computer works
when they're trying to render
even like facial recognition--
looking for certain points
on the face and the eyes
to measure distances
and things--
and it all goes back to this
particular period of time.
This single point of
view enabled architects
and designers to figure out
the proportional relationships
of buildings as they would
fit together in a plan.
And this is showing how all
these diagonals are converging
on a single point of view.
As an architectural
photographer,
with a view camera,
you learn how
to actually move that
vanishing point around,
and that's one of the things
that gives a unique look
to a large format images.
Again, with perspective,
with design, this
enables you to do handbooks--
show how parts are
related to each other.
And that's the one thing that I
found the most difficult thing
to do photographically, because
photography sort of deals
with surface and
appearance that it's
very difficult to
accomplish that,
but when you mix photographs
with measured drawings,
such as done by the Historic
American Engineering Record,
then you get a real mixture.
One of the things that's
going on these days
that I find slightly
distressing is
that historic preservationists
are getting very adept at using
these laser scanners to record
very precise measurements
and shapes of things
and they can even
put a skin on these drawing
with photographs, but in a way,
there's no interpretation
of them because of that.
Maybe they will evolve some
kind of interpretation,
but I think-- as a black
and white photographer,
I think one of the things I
enjoyed so much over the years
was sort of try and
look at these things
and see what the
soul of them was.
So one of my first
what I regarded
as kind of a successful
image, but you can see,
here I am using that
vanishing point perspective.
And this type of view is
very elemental to most
architectural
photography in that
almost all architectural
photographers start
with an elevation.
Of any building
they're photographing,
they're going to photograph
the principal elevation.
In a way, they're
searching for the views
that the architect is
intending to orient you as you
walk through the building.
You can see in this
campus that we're on,
there's a lot of very
intentional design
in how the architects want you
to flow through the buildings
and experience the other spaces.
I started my photography
rather unusually.
I mean, I had not really--
I was not like an adolescent
photographer or anything,
but I was a freshman
in college and we
had these independent study
periods which have become very
common in a lot of colleges.
I mean, they almost
all have January terms.
The school I went to had two
independent study periods
a year of one month long.
And in my freshman
year of college,
I got the opportunity
to go to Haiti.
I mostly wanted to go there
to practice my French.
And a professor said, take
my Pentax camera with you.
And so I did.
I rolled up 20 rolls
of black and white film
and 10 or 15 rolls of
Kodachrome and found myself
photographing the architecture
as much as anything.
I did get some nice people
photographs but those certainly
weren't my strongest images, but
as I went over these images--
and I came across
these negatives
in one of my shoe
boxes just last summer
and scanned just to
see what I had there,
and I was surprised at how
architectural they were.
But let me identify this.
This is in Cap-Haitien,
the northern part of Haiti.
This is a wonderful dome church.
I forget what the
exact name of it
but it's in the-- it's
the Cathedral de Milao,
built in 1805--
just almost sort of at the
end of the Haitian revolution.
And it's sort of interesting
these connections--
these disparate connections
between places--
but the French did
not sort of willingly
give up Haiti as a colony.
It was their wealthiest
colony by far.
But basically, malaria
beat the French soldiers,
and at the time, Jefferson was
very interested in achieving
sort of at least to guard
the Mississippi Valley
and they went to France to
negotiate for just New Orleans.
They were interested in
that just to kind of protect
to keep the British from being
able to go up the Mississippi
River.
And in the negotiations,
they said, well,
how would you like
just sort of the rest
of the French territory?
And so basically half the
country was purchased,
and we can thank the Haitians
for that in many ways.
Going further into
Cap-Haitien, this
is a wonderful palace
that was heavily damaged.
This was built by
King Christophe.
It was called Sans-Souci.
It's just south of Cap-Haitien.
These shots were done
in 1966, by the way.
This was under the
Papa Doc regime.
I had a month to travel around.
And I guess the thing
that really seduced me
to photography in some
ways is that I found myself
ending up in places I just
ordinarily wouldn't end up in.
And I like to sort of
promote photography to people
as a way to slow down
your visitation to a place
rather than speeding it up.
I'm sure you've been
to the national parks
where people jump out of the
car, photograph half dome,
jump back in the car,
go to the next site,
but photography can
also be sort of a more
meditative and a slowing
down process as a way
to explore areas as well.
And that's the way I like
to think of it and maybe
that's why I've always liked
large format photography.
And even though I am currently
shooting a lot digitally,
I try to use it in a
more meditative way.
Going up the hill
from Sans-Souci
is the largest fortress in
North America, the Citadel de la
Ferriere, and it was built by
King Christophe out of fear
that the French might return
and try and take away,
but really, the
malaria did them in
and they were probably exhausted
from all of Napoleon's doings
in Moscow and everywhere
else at that time.
And here's further up.
This structure has
been much stabilized
since I photographed it in '66.
I think they've kind
of lined up the cannons
and probably pointed up
the mortar a little bit
but it was quite
a wonderful sight.
And here's a little piece
of mortar just sitting
there waiting for the French to
come back, but they never did.
The photographers that I sort
of look up to and think back
on the most are like
the French masters
who conducted major surveys.
This is the French
photographer Baldus,
and there were the great
American William Henry Jackson
and numerous other
great photographers
that did surveys
of the West that
are credited with the founding
of the National Park Service
with the work that they did.
And back when I was doing
research at the Library
of Congress back in the '60s--
the prints and
photographs division
is a great place to visit
if you love photography
because you used to have to
submit copyrights to them.
They started amassing a
major photographic collection
in the early 20th century.
So they've got the Arnold
Genthe of the San Francisco
earthquake and these
great photographs there,
and those images are what
have always inspired me
in terms of image
quality and just
the substance of the
photographs that they take.
This is a bridge that I
photographed in Cleveland,
Ohio, the Abbey Avenue Bridge.
I pointed out to
you that since--
I don't think I was familiar
with that Baldus photograph
when I did it, but when
you're photographing bridges,
bridges are really great sort
of documents of engineering
thinking at any given time.
You can even see
it around here when
you look at the
highway overpasses that
have been built since the
earthquake that you had
in the early '90s that
are much more beefed up
and things like that.
And like this
bridge, you can see--
and you'll notice
these lace channels
and these small details and
rivets and pin connections.
I mean, the engineers
were jumping hoops
with the materials
and the things
that the steel
manufacturers could produce
at that particular time.
As the steel mills were able
to put out bigger pieces,
you could make a similar bridge
with fewer pieces and faster.
And so these are ways that
people that study bridges
will look at them.
If you see a pin-connected
metal truss bridge,
that's probably going to be
built before 1900, for example.
One of my other major
influences is Ansel Adams,
who definitely works
in the tradition
of the great 19th
century photographers.
In this photograph
I made in Butte,
Montana in the
early '80s of the--
I would sit out
there in January.
It sort of marks one of the
coldest assignments I ever had.
But ARCO, which owned
most of the mine sites,
was tearing down
these head frames
and they wanted me
to get out there
to document these head frames.
The temperature was about
eight degrees below,
which is probably not
that cold for Butte,
but it was about the most
cold that a camera shutter
would perform without sort of
removing all the lubricants.
You have to take the lubricants
out of the camera shutter
if you're going to
work colder than that.
But so it was my homage
to Ansel storm clearing
over Butte, Montana.
And this is a bridge
in New Portland, Maine
that sort of illustrates
hybridization
between the covered bridge
technology where you're
covering the tower
structures to protect them
from the weather and
the winters there.
The reason covered
bridges are covered
is because they make the
trusses last about 100% longer.
And just to illustrate, this
is looking from the other side,
looking west.
And here's a detail
of the anchorage.
I mean, that's the most
important part of a suspension
bridge is that's
what's holding it up,
where it's going
into the ground.
It's probably some big
kind of literal anchor
that's buried in the
ground that's holding it.
And just for
comparison, this is what
the anchorage to the
George Washington
Bridge crossing the Hudson River
in New York City looks like.
And here, you can really see
how the suspension bridge is
made because it's done
over a year or so time
where each cable is made
from a single span of wire
going back and forth hundreds
and hundreds of times
until they assemble this
array of cables and ropes
and put it into one big cable.
Climbing up through the
superstructure of the George
Washington Bridge--
probably my favorite bridge that
I've ever gotten to document--
this was before 9/11.
I don't know whether
they would have permitted
me to photograph it since then.
But we were trying at
that time to document
major civil and
mechanical engineering
landmarks for our collection
and they were very amenable.
A lot of these folks that
work for the port authority
were headquartered in the World
Trade building at that time,
so I imagine we lost a number
of folks when that happened.
And here's an aerial of the
George Washington Bridge.
Apparently Ammann was very
influenced by erector sets,
a friend of mine has told
me, and it has this kind
of erector set look to it.
But the other thing
that's going on here
is that it's a bit over-built
because it was designed
to be clad with stone to give
it that kind of New York-y kind
of solid look, but
the critics just
liked it so much showing
the structure itself
that they stuck with that.
And here is a good profile
looking downstream.
I'd finished shooting
the bridge that week.
I was on the way home
across the bridge
and the Hudson was
just this mirror calm
and the light was just
this gorgeous light,
so we got down to
this little state park
where we could get this view
with a deceptively placid look
of New York City.
I love that contrast of it.
And here is the ancestor
to the George Washington
Bridge, the Brooklyn Bridge,
which we're all familiar with.
The trademark of the bridge
is those diagonal stays.
There was a big concern about
how the counteracting sway
and avoiding the cyclical
sinusoidal movements
of the bridge decks.
As the 20th century
proceeded, the engineers
got a little more daring
with thinning the road deck
and over-relying on the
weight of the bridge
deck to keep that
from happening,
until Galloping Gertie
disaster took place
and then they sort of
went, eh, we went a little
too far in that direction.
But you know, mistakes
do have to happen.
And this was taken around
'83 during the centennial
of the Brooklyn Bridge opening,
which was almost 100 years
after its opening.
You can still see
the World Trade
Center framed through it there.
And to build a
suspension bridge,
you've got to make wire and
cable, so I'm putting in this--
this is where the
Roebling factory
in Trenton, New Jersey with
a little miniature series
of buildings trying to express
what they're doing there.
They're making wire rope.
And this is actually
in the same area.
This is a rope-making machine--
quite an elaborate machine
with this clockwork mechanism
that was adjusted so that
you could do different winds
and lays of wire
around a single cable
depending on how
much flexibility you
wanted to design into the rope.
This cable became very
important in the development
and the building
of the Panama Canal
in terms of its construction.
Certainly one of the more
magnificent structures
I got to photograph
during my career.
And it's a very
interesting structure
because the canals
and the railroads
were sort of made-- in a way,
the railroads eclipsed canals
as a way of moving stuff
around, but the thing
that makes the Panama
Canal work as a mechanism
is actually a lot of
railroad technology
to open these gates such as
this-- this enormous gate here,
which is what, about
10 stories tall,
they had to think of different
systems to control it with.
They were not directly
connected to the control tower
there, which I'm going
to show you here.
AUDIENCE: Was that prior
picture taken on top of a gate?
JET LOWE: What?
AUDIENCE: Were you
out on top of gate?
JET LOWE: Yeah.
Yes.
There was a few--
you'll see back-- you know,
there were some walkways.
I don't know that it's shown,
but there were some walkways
and there were some gates
that you could cross over to.
But anyway, this was
the control room.
The Smithsonian was just
fascinated with these control
tables, which are kind of
pretty remarkable things
because they kind of--
as I'll show you
in a second, they
kind of create a simul view--
a virtual view--
of what's going on
in the canal by these
indicators here.
And you can see here
they're indicating
that these gates are closed.
This sign here I think
might say that it's locked
and that people are
walking across it
as a way to warn the
operator that no,
you better not open
that one there.
And you can see here that
that canal gate is open.
So while these
photographs were being
made during this annual
overhaul that they do-- they
just kind of do it like they
repair roads around here.
They close down one lane
and so all the ships
have to wait their turns to go
east or west while they repair
one set of chambers and then
they go onto the other side
and repair the other
side of chambers.
That was really kind
of a unique opportunity
to get there to photograph
during this particular process,
and they took me all
around on the inside.
Underneath these control
tables, for this thing
to work, the biggest fear of a
canal designer and an engineer,
if you don't open the
gates in the right order,
you have the danger
of draining the lake
in the middle of the peninsula.
If the lake were to
start flowing out,
there's no way you could close
those gates if you don't do it
in the right order.
It would take a year
or so to build up
enough water in the lake
to make the canal run.
So they developed this
interlocking table
that sort of uses a
lot of early logic--
if, and, and-- so
that the operator
can only go into
certain sequence.
It's called interlocks
and it's kind of
based on switching technology
that the railroad devised
in the 19th century.
And so these are the
little electric motors
underneath the canal
gates that mimic what's
happening with the
real gates, and they're
little electric motors connected
to the actual canal gates that
send the signal back to this.
So it's like a prototypical
fly-by wire system
if you know what that is as
far as airplane controls go.
So rather than
directly controlling
the elevators of an airplane,
you have an electrical system,
or you have electric
steering in your Prius,
for example, rather than a
mechanical direct connection.
And so then you have all
these interconnections
that prevent you from
opening it or closing it
in the wrong sequence.
What this enabled--
I throw this image in.
This train exists
here in Nome, Alaska.
It was hauling gold out
of the sands out of Nome.
But because the Panama
Canal was not completed,
it had to be brought all
the way around from New York
City around South America
and up to Nome Alaska
during the 1890s gold rush.
And I just find that a kind
of pretty remarkable story.
It was part of the elevated
line in New York City,
and when they retired it, they
shipped it all the way around
to Nome for the gold rush.
While we're up in Alaska,
as part of exploitation
of materials and
industrialization
that was taking place
in the 19th century,
this bridge was built
called the Million Dollar
Bridge-- the only
bridge in the world
that I know of that's actually
built between two glaciers.
And when it was
built in 1912, they
did not know whether
the glaciers were
going to expand and
tear it away or not,
but it had to be built in
the depth of the winter
while the river was
completely frozen up so
that if it were
completed abutment
to abutment, before a breakup,
it would probably hold.
But they had to get it--
if it were not
completed, it would just
get washed downstream with
the breakup of the ice.
What you see also
here is the result
of the earthquake of 1963,
the Alaskan earthquake, which
I think is still the largest
recorded earthquake that's
occurred.
That's since been repaired.
But I think that's the
Miles Glacier to the south,
and then if you're on top of
the truss and look to the north,
this is the other glacier.
Cordova Alaska is sort of
over there beyond the trees,
and people will drive
up to a road that's
just across the stream
from the glaciers
and honk at it to make it calve.
And it sounds like a
little thunderstorm
off in the distance
as the glaciers
are falling off the end.
It's this deep rumble.
Back to another great bridge,
this is Bellows Falls, Vermont.
This is a bridge that we
lost in the late '70s.
I was just finishing up
this project and a young man
walked up to me and
said, how would you
like me to walk up to
the top of that bridge
there and get a picture of me?
And I said, well, sure.
But engineering objects kind of
inspire those kind of things,
and I think really great
engineering, like such
as the Golden Gate
Bridge, can have
the capability of actually
enhancing putting focus
on a natural environment.
And the details on
the bridge plates
often gives you information
about the politics
of what's going on--
who got the funding going.
So my interest in
bridges has been--
since retirement in 2013, I've
continued to take pictures,
and I'm always sort
of on the lookout
for the great landmarks.
And this was one of the great
landmarks of the 19th century,
was the Garabit Viaduct
in southern France.
Really a quite wonderful,
elegant structure.
You'll see it in most any
Art History 101 course.
And then also worth a
trip across the pond
is a very recently built bridge.
This is almost a British--
it's in southern France
not far from the Garabit.
It's called the Millau Viaduct
and is by Richard Norman
Foster, the British architect.
But the firm that built this
is basically a descendent
of the Eiffel firm.
And these are the towers.
This bridge is tall
enough that you could fit
the Eiffel Tower underneath it.
So it's quite an
impressive structure.
One of the things
that we've learned
in our technology in the
19th and 20th century
is handling heat.
Maybe you all have gone
north to northern California
and crossed the
Carquinez Strait bridge
and looked at those
abandoned ships that
are gathered up off to the
right, called the Ghost
Fleet by some folks.
I got to get out there as one of
the more stranger environments
I've gotten to get into.
And we were photographing
oil tankers,
and this is the engine
room of an oil tanker,
showing the steam turbines
and the reduction gears.
Now this is kind of
a hot rod oil tanker
because it had to be able
to keep up with the fleet,
because at the time, they
didn't have enough technology
to make the reduction gears.
But for the oil tankers
that needed to keep up
with the fleet, they had those.
And this is the boiler
room of the same.
You know, pretty-- that's
a hot place to work.
But this technology,
sort of often--
you know, after photographing
this stuff for the time,
it makes it seem
like, you know, it's
not that big of a leap to
the shuttle discoverer.
This is the bridge to
I got down to Cape
Canaveral just before--
when they were sort
of fitting it up
for going to the Udvar-Hazy
Museum in Washington, DC.
This is a stitched image
from two negatives,
showing the full control panel.
The windshield is
completely blacked out
to protect it from
the work that they
were doing to get it
ready to go to the museum.
If you were to turn it
around from the same spot,
you would look here and
see the control panel
to the Canadian arm, and
in dealing with things
in the cargo bay and also being
able to ingress and egress
out of the shuttle when
you're out of space.
And this is a view
into the-- you
could fit a good-sized yellow
school bus in this cargo bay.
So the shuttle discoverer
is a pretty large machine.
NASA thought of it as the
most complicated machine
on the planet, which could
very well be with the systems
that it takes to make
that thing reusable
and controllable as it was.
To be able to operate
the machine out in space
while in orbit, you need
to rehearse what you're
going to be doing,
and they would
time to the minute what the
extravehicular operators would
be doing.
And they would do it in this--
what's called a neutral buoyancy
chamber in Huntsville, Alabama.
And that's what
you're seeing here.
This is an underwater
shot through one
of those portholes
of the Canadian arm.
And here's Leslie
Wickman, an astronaut--
she was an
extravehicular specialist
astronaut that
specialized in operating
outside of the shuttle.
At this particular
time, I don't think--
when I did this
shot, I don't think
they had gotten up and done the
repairs on the web telescope
yet, but I think they were
getting ready for that
at that particular time.
And so she's just kind of
completing her rehearsal.
When they go in there, they
have to be weighted down.
They have other scuba
divers to help them out,
but they do time it down to
the minute what exactly they'll
be doing.
And here's the gloves.
To make an astronaut suit,
it's about a million dollars
for each suit that
an astronaut weighs.
It's the cost of those things.
I mean, you can imagine
what the suit has to do.
You know, operate in a vacuum,
keep you warm on the cool side
and cool you down
on the hot side
and all that kind of stuff.
And then have these gloves
so that you can actually
manipulate tools and
things like that.
This is one of them more bizarre
kind of almost kludgy things
that NASA did.
I mean, scientists and engineers
are very pragmatic creatures,
as I'm sure you all very
well know, but this transport
system of the shuttle--
that 747 that they use is
apparently just completely
empty on the inside.
I mean, I think there
are like just a few sort
of special seats behind where
the bridge is to run the thing,
and then I'm sure the shuttle
just has everything out of it
that they can get out of it.
This is the underside
of the shuttle, which
is kind of neat
that you can really
sense what an aged
ship it was at the time
going into the museum.
And that it had gone
more than a million miles
around the planet.
And you can even see the space
dirt on the shuttle tiles.
And just as an example
of how difficult it
was to prepare the shuttle for
re-entry and re-use, each one
of those tiles, they
have to kind of re-inject
some kind of substance
into them to protect them
against absorbing too much
moisture while they're on land.
And each tile takes
a different quantity
and they're all
completely numbered.
It's like this very
homemade kind of machine
and that's why
it's so expensive.
Just to start on a whole
different pilgrimage
from going into outer space,
since I've been retired,
I've always been interested
in architecture of all sorts,
and one of my favorite
places that we visited
in France was an area called
the Puy-en-Velay, which
is kind of a pilgrimage spot.
And it's this French town in
the Massif Central of France
that basically occupies
a volcanic caldera.
So these little churches
and stuff on tops
of remnants of
volcanoes and things,
so it's a major Christian
pilgrimage space,
and here, this stairway is
where a penitence might crawl up
to the church on their
knees in medieval times--
I don't think in the
20th century anymore--
maybe to go visit
the Black Madonna.
And the original--
there's a whole bunch
of interesting stuff about
these Black Madonnas,
but apparently one
of the originals
was captured during the
Crusades from Constantinople
or something like
that at that time.
During the French Revolution,
a lot of these icons
were destroyed, and
so this is probably
one that was a reproduction that
was made in the 19th century
by the--
I just found it an
extraordinarily droll--
sort of a wonderful thing.
Icon for what it is.
And so in my talk here
with this portal view,
this is still-- you're
up at the top of the hill
outside of this church, and
this would be one of the places
where you might
begin a new journey.
This was one of
the beginning spots
if you were going to do the
pilgrimage to Santiago de
Compostela, and no
telling what would happen
and no telling where
we'll go from there.
And that's where
I'll end my talk.
If there's any questions, I'll
be happy to entertain them.
[APPLAUSE]
ED BACHER: Thank you, Jet.
If you have any
questions, there's
a mic in the middle
of the room there.
I'll start off with
a Dory question.
Ryan in Sunnyvale
asks, what do you
think has been lost from
the conversion of film
to digital photography
and what advice
would you give to digital
photographers these days?
JET LOWE: Well, on
that particular issue,
I think of digital and film
as like two different beasts.
And I'm sort of fairly
ecumenical on that,
although I would still
think that whether you're
digital or not, I'd
highly recommend
shooting film and trying to
deal with it because a lot
of the kind of language that
you see in Photoshop derives
from film--
usage of film.
The things like the Dodge
and Burn tool, and even
the Unsharp tool in
Photoshop is a result
of graphic designers using
two images to create a greater
amount of edge around an
image to create the sharpness,
and that's probably what the
computer program is doing, too.
But so I just
really think of them
as completely different
kinds of things.
The thing that I like about film
is that you can capture things
in one moment.
Like there's a thing--
to do some of the
things in digital
that you would do in film, you
have to take multiple images,
for example, to get the contrast
range, whereas with film, you
can overexpose and
underdevelop and compress
that range together to get
a different effect than you
can with digital.
But they really are--
I am told that actually film--
I wouldn't say as so much
it's making a comeback,
but the companies are selling
more film with increasing time.
Film is more of a
tactile medium and maybe
it has also to do with--
there was debate back
in the '30s whether it's
light particles or is it waves.
And I think of film
as particles and I
think of digital as waves.
ED BACHER: Question.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for the
talk and the pictures.
So if someone is
going to use digital--
which, sorry to say
that, but are there
any digital cameras
that you would recommend
or that you yourself use?
JET LOWE: Oh gosh.
I mean, you know, the
point and shoot cameras--
even though the iPhone
and the Android phones,
they do magnificent images.
And there's whole groups
of fine art photographers
that are sort of using those
as their medium because
of the particular kind of
image quality that they use.
And so I think that's--
you know, whatever works,
in a way, is what I would--
AUDIENCE: What are
some things you think
about when composing a photo?
Some things you think about
when you're composing a photo?
JET LOWE: When I
give workshops, I
tell people to think
a lot about what's
going on around the
edges, because whenever
you're taking the picture,
you're cutting things out.
And so you're always
making a decision,
do I want this or
do I not want that?
So if you think a
lot around the edges,
that makes a big difference.
Now if you're
photographing architecture,
I really like to encourage
people to try and sort of get
as high as possible so
that the camera back
is as parallel to parallel
vertical lines as possible.
The architectural
photography is sort of
like a subdiscipline of
photography, and so in a way,
it's got stricter
rules, and in many ways,
it's harder to kind of make
a stylistic differentiation
between one's work
and another's work
because it's maybe like fugue
writing or something like that.
AUDIENCE: Let me
piggyback on that one
just a little bit,
and maybe this
is sacrilege talking to you,
but for scale and context,
I find some architectural
photography includes
human subjects, like you had the
one on the Bellows Falls Bridge
there.
Any advice on including
human subjects in?
JET LOWE: Personally, I like to
have people in my photographs.
Another way I depart from a lot
of architectural photographers
is I like having automobiles
in my photographs,
because over time, those
automobiles will really
date the image.
Because when you see
a photograph taken
in the '60s, for example, just
by looking at the automobiles,
you know when it was taken.
But sometimes people
and automobiles
can detract from
maybe the design
or whatever you're trying to
capture so there's no really
fixed rules on that or
not, but generally, I
like to have people in my
photographs for the scale
and the human use
of the structure.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
ED BACHER: Any other questions?
I have one.
You showed us a difficult
place to photograph,
at least from your
comfort, in Butte.
Do you have a favorite
place that you photographed
or a favorite item
that you photographed?
JET LOWE: Well I didn't
show it in this sequence,
but I think one of the more
wondrous places I got to get to
was the leper colony on
Moloka'I Island in Kalaupapa.
And because I work for the
Historic American Engineering
Record, what we were
documenting was the water supply
system to the leper colony,
and so it involved hiking up
these steep ginger
root streams to get
to these sedimentation
ponds and stuff
like that to kind of
clarify the water.
But it's a small peninsula that
sticks out on sort of the north
side of the island, I guess
created by a lava flow,
so it's really isolated from
the rest of the island by this
2,000-foot sea cliff, and
it's a pretty dramatic place.
Some people say, when
you're out in Hawaii,
you really can feel
like you're on a planet,
and so I guess Hawaii is
one of my favorite places
on the Earth.
ED BACHER: Cool.
Well thank you very much.
Great to have you.
[APPLAUSE]